歡迎收看理財達人秀最受歡迎的教學單元
標谷在現當
有我們的朱家宏朱老師
K線之神來教大家一系列技術線型操作的技巧
哇不知不覺也做了非常多極樂
但是目前照好有發現
因為坊間真的仿冒朱老師的詐騙群組太多太多了
最近有一個朋友一直來我們這邊留言
我一直說是朱老師騙他
不是唷各位朋友
如果你們真的上了詐騙的檔
拜託還是務必去報警喔
因為在我們這邊留言
我們也沒有辦法幫你把錢追回來
最重要的是要認清自己是被騙了
是被詐騙了喔
所以去報警雖然不見得警方也能處理
但是至少要有認知喔
下一次千萬不要隨隨便便把錢
會給您根本不認識的人喔
好 那今天要來教什麼呢
很多人說在股票市場
也有被詐騙的感覺
明明別人買的時候
一直飆一直飆一直飆
怎麼我買的時候就一直跌
一直跌一直跌呢
問題在哪裡
問題在今天要教你的
乖離率
如果股票已經漲到
乖離率非常高了
小心喔
你可能會是被震出去的
那一隻白老鼠喔
所以這邊的話剛好
因為最近標股太多了
對不對 之前漲軍工出能
最近漲AI
每一檔都長到抖翹這樣上去
事實上這時候接入就要很留意的
很可能被燙到
對對
我們今天特別告訴大家
我們的這個乖離率
那他就是有他的作用
為什麼
乖離率
這個我們有一個叫六狗理論
六狗理論
對
其實在我們的所有的事情
都是這個理論
要平衡理論
對不對
一定要平衡
你長多了就要跌回來
跌多了就會長回來
這也叫平衡
那六狗理論也很簡單
就是如果你帶了一隻狗到外面去遛
你是不是有一隻牽了一隻狗的
這個神子
他跑的再遠
然後你還是要把他拉過來
沒錯
所以最後還是走到你主人身邊
這個附近
所以這就是我們股價的六狗理論
好那我們來看一下
如果你的股價在你的
這個均線的上面
我們叫正乖離
跌到下面我們叫負乖離
那這個乖離就是跟均線的距離的百分比
這叫乖離
那乖離怎麼去算也很簡單
我們隨便一個點
比如說在這個位置
今天的收盤
減掉你均線的那個均值
那個電腦每天都會秀給你看的
你都可以去
減了一個價差
這個價差去除上你均線的均值
就是你用的均線
為什麼 因為有人用10均
有人用20均
如果你是要看二十軍的乖離
那你就把收盤價減掉二十軍
當天的軍價
這個減了就一個價差
去除這個二十軍的軍價
那就會有一個百分比出來了
那這個百分比我們就叫乖離率
叫乖離率
股價離軍線越遠
你算的乖離率就越大
站的百分比就越大
股價離越接近軍線
那乖離率就越小
所以我們基本上我們就來研究
跟股價偏離的這個程度
會有什麼影響
在我們操作上要注意些什麼對不對
那我一直跟大家講
技術分析這個叫指標
那指標只是一個輔助
來幫助我們能夠去更加的精準的
來判別這支股票現在的位置
它是可以買還是要準備賣
這個重點就在這
像這支股票從這邊就一路的上漲
那我們就看他
從第一天上漲
跟這個二十軍的月線
就有一個距離了
而且每天的距離越拉越大越拉
這個表示乖離率一直在上升
那乖離率上升
就代表你一直在賺錢
因為他每天的乖離率都在增加
好 到了某一天
比如說這個位置
這個最高點
乖離率過高
他就開始要回來了
回到哪裡呢
他就要回到月線這邊
那如果把月線跌破了
距離月線太遠容易回到月線
可是如果把它跌破
它就變成負乖離
它開始變負的
那為什麼會變負的
剛才的公司各位如果還記得的話
就知道你的收盤價減掉均線
那因為你在收盤
你在均線的下面
所以你低的數字去減高的數字
就會變負的 對不對
那這個負的再去除上這個均線均值
那個就是復乖離
所以在均線的下面
那這一段就叫做復乖離
所以其實也很容易
你看哪條均線
你的股價在上面就正乖離
你的股價在下面就是復乖離
是
那在這個地方
我們大概給大家做一個參考
好
那我講過
股票的漲跌
它的不確定性是非常多的
假如這是一個小標股
那個阻力就一直拉一直拉
它有可能乖離會非常大
但還是沒疊
有的股價就很溫吞
就慢慢走 它沒什麼乖離
所以我們大概一個平均數
因為有大型股 有小型股
大家去做一個平均數的一個參考
如果你去看五均的乖離
大概超過五證五或富五
這個大概都要注意
五均的股價就容易要下跌
那實際上如果大家一系列看
這個我的這個技術分析的節目
都有講這個道理
為什麼我們都講
你沿著五軍操作對不對
大概長個三天嘛
那長三天跟五軍的乖離
大概就是在五趴
那這時候就是在高檔
做多就在高檔
你不要去追了
因為他容易回來
那如果你去看十軍操作
有人是用十軍操作嘛
那你的乖離到了七趴 八趴
那大概這個在高檔
要注意一下 容易回來
那我們大部分都是用二十軍去看
二十軍因為它是一個月線
它是可以看比較長期的乖離
我講這是平均值
然後等一下我們會
因股本的大小不同 會設定不一樣
那平均大概十二
這個乖離率十二
也就是說正常的一些股票
你離二十軍乖離到十二的話
你就要注意 注意什麼就是
你不能跌了
不能跌
你可以漲嘛
因為冠儀率可以超過嘛
對 比如說你標股
你就會超過十二
超過十五
都沒關係
但是你就不要跌
因為你已經太高了
離軍線太遠了
這個主人會幫你拉回來
所以主人這樣一拉的時候
你叫警覺
他就要跌了
股價進出與冠儀率的指標應用
一般都是二十軍為主
以月線為主
那各位要知道
這個軍線叫葛蘭壁發明的
我們有一集有講過
葛蘭壁的八大法則
對 葛蘭壁的八大法則
那條軍線就是二十軍
他就是用二十軍來做進出的
所以大家也可以去複習一下
類似
這個比率是給大家做一個參考
因為我們現行或者像這樣的
關於利率
它是一個經驗值加機率的累積
沒錯 沒錯
就是說他只是警告你
你已經離太遠了
如果正關於利率
就表告訴你 你已經賺太多了
好不好 開心啊
對 我們的操作心法都有講標談
只要他不長 你應該也要賣一趟
這個就是最重要的要點
我們看很多的指標
都要知道說 這個指標
只是在警告你 給你一個暗示
那你如果看不懂 那就沒辦法了
好 那正觀一的計算
我們剛才已經有公示
比如說今天這個最高的94.3
那今天的這個20均的均值是72.76
在電腦上都會有
如果你後面都沒有發生
最後今天收盤就會在這裡表現
那現在的表現是這一根
是這一根的20均
好 那你就把它剪一剪
再除上72.76
所以它的乖離已經到了三成了
就非常高了
那非常高代表什麼意思
有兩個 我常常講我們做股票
其實就做兩件事
一個是你要買還是要賣
這個地方就叫你不要買
因為它已經乖離都超過三成了
那這個地方是你有多單準備賣
就這樣子 所以那你什麼時候賣
就是乖離過高 出現黑K
你就要準備了
它大概就要下來了
所以你如果有這樣子的認知
乖離率對你來說就有幫助了
因為很多人賺錢都有一個問題
他都不知道什麼時候賣
他常會問可不可以賣
是今天要賣嗎
還是明天要賣
或是賣飛了又覺得很賤心
對
但是如果你乖離已經超過
我們正常的乖離
就表示你已經
這個短線你已經算很多了
算不少囉
對 不要貪了
如果他不長你就賣
你看他又跌回三天
所以這個就是
我們學乖離的
主要的目的
我們不是在
在學一個什麼去背書啊什麼
就是我學了以後
我的股票我就去觀察
那這支股票也一樣
跌跌跌到最低一點
五零點五
那他這個月限是六二點一
所以乖離是十八點六
富乖離
那這個是空單回補的
不是在另外的
不要在這裡做空
是
記得
做這兩件事
那有人會問
那可不可以做多啊
那就是賭他反彈
不要賭
這個補票一聽到賭就大
你這一賭啊
這個九賭必輸啊
不要賭啊
好
因為這個是一個空頭反彈
所以我們不要去
我們就記得你有空單要回補
你空手不要空
那為什麼不要空
因為他是乖離過大
那可是他是空頭啊
所以基本上你是準備下一次做空
而不是這一次來做多
所以這一點要把它分清楚
那這樣你大概
這個乖離對你來說就很有用了
我整理了這張表
那這張表就是乖離
跟股價進出的一些指標應用
把剛才的一些觀念各位懂了
那現在我們就用這張表來做
假如你是一支多頭股票
那股價上漲跟月限的乖離
正乖離在十趴以上
我們就叫15 20
剛才都到20多了
處於高檔容易回檔修正
你知道這個時候
你都股票容易回來修正
你心裡面就
電積的這件事不要忘了
他隨時都會回來
那策略空手不要追高買進
多單準備停利
這樣子就很清楚了
下次你看到有這麼高乖離的
你就趕快記得這句話
你空手不要去追高
然後你有多單就恭喜你了
你可以準備停利
那這個新法 股價維持在正乖離
趨勢不變 多單續報
如果你是做長線的
你的 你其實這個就告訴你
沒有跌破二十均嘛
對不對 跌破二十均就復乖離
就變復乖離了 對
只要你沒有跌破復乖離
你就繼續報
表示他在月線上
一直在走一直在走
可能走到中間 有稍微的
回來一天兩天
又走 然後又回來兩三天
但是他都是正乖離
如果你做長線的
趨勢不變多單你就續報
他 因為他維持在正乖離
這個就是很重要
做長線人的心法
因為做短線你跌破五軍就賣了
跟二十軍就沒有什麼太大關係
好 那重點在這裡囉
你是不是多頭做得很過癮
乖離10%以上 獲利也很高
當股價轉成復乖離
趨勢轉弱 趨勢容易反轉
所以意思也就是說
你的股價跌破月線
我們剛才有一張圖嘛 對不對
正乖離跌破月線就變富乖離
上面是正的 下面是富的嘛 對不對
所以這個時候
你趨勢可能是多頭的回檔
但是你已經轉弱了
因為你的股價變富乖離
所以你要特別的注意
好 孔
那當然也就是告訴你啦
做股票跌破月限
這個你就趕快賣了
不要再爆了好不好
因為他已經變富乖離了
其實正乖離他的含義就是說
做多的人再賺錢
因為你在軍線上
富乖離就表示
你最近買的人開始賠錢
那我們有個觀念
做股票千萬不要賠錢
所以一看到賠錢你就趕快跑
這個是重要的觀念
好 反過來如果是空頭
富乖離在8以上
他就在第一檔很容易反彈
我這邊解釋一下
為什麼剝頭是十
為什麼復乖離是八呢
為什麼復乖離到八就很危險了
對他要談
其實剛才的公式有關
剛剛各位有沒有想到
這個公式是怎麼算的
你的股價跟均線的均值的差
你正乖離的時候
這個差是除什麼
除下面的均線
因為你正乖離均線在下面
所以你除的數字是比較小的
對
復乖離也是同樣的差
可是你要往上
對 你要除上面
所以你的比例就會變小
比例會變小
大家體會一下
不過你了解了你就不用背了
因為你就是對嘛
這個我一除
除那麼大的數字
所以只有8%
可是已經在復乖離很大了
好 同樣是10塊
12塊跟8塊是不一樣的
不一樣的
因為你除了那個分母不一樣
這個分母比較大
所以重點在這
所以你要去找一個空頭
富乖離跟多頭量
有超過15%的 很難找
你很難找到的
跌太慘
對
好像跌慘也跌不到15%
也跌不到15%
對
這也就是說為什麼做空
沒有做多的利潤來的高
到你一模一樣
對不對
因為你獲利
對 你獲利是除高成本
不一樣的
那處於低檔反彈修正
空手就不要做空
雖然看它滴滴滴好過癮
可是你不要空
空單就準備回補
那股價維持在復乖離
趨勢不變
你如果有空單你就繼續報
就是說它沒有上二十均
你就繼續報
所以各位把它結合一下
我們平常的技術分析
其實它是一貫的
這個邏輯都是一樣的
我們平常也講
空頭在月線下 月線下彎
你就可以一直做空嘛
你不要跑到月線上
跑到月線上
他就可能又轉強了
那趨勢就容易變化
所以你如果有空單
就千萬不要在月線上不要做空
是
一定要在月線下
復乖離去做空
好 那我這邊稍微的叮嚀一下
股價處於反漲反跌
那這時候乖離率就沒有辦法效果了
因為他會貼著這些均線往上走
大概就是跟二子軍上下5%這樣
就沒有 那個你就沒有什麼太多的參考價值
所以我們乖離率一定是當它變大的時候
你就要提醒自己
這個乖離率不一樣
你的策略要做什麼
如果它不漲了 我就要賣
或者不跌了 我就要回補
這個隨時因為股價本來有的時候玩玩玩
突然又大漲了
所以你都要隨時去調整
這個乖離率的應用
如果還漲緩跌就沒有什麼太大的用途
不過朱老師 乖離率變很大的時候
我覺得應該是給我們一個警惕
但不是一個一定要賣的準則
對 例如說你常講
標股我們可能抱著就守五日均先
有的乖離搞不好都四十趴五十趴了
所以還是以守這個均線為優先
我剛剛有講指標做參考
不是給你做進出的
就好像KG指標八十
也沒有叫你賣
它會動畫嘛 對不對
是一樣的
所有的觀念
只要你能夠觀念正確
就不會誤導你了
不會誤導說
喔 那乖離死我
就趕快賣
我剛剛已經講了
你這個乖離過大了
要跌下來你才賣
你看這邊有看到AK
那是不是就要下來了
乖離過大了
不漲了 那他就要下來
好 那我們一個股票
剛剛有講
股價正乖離
我如果有多單我就繼續報
那正乖離從哪邊
從這邊開始的話
股價出現正乖離
跑到20均上了
可是這邊呢
股價出現復乖離了
你有多單錢你趕快走
可能你在第一時間沒有賣嗎
這個乖離過大你沒有賣
可是變復乖離你趕快走
還好也沒有賺到錢
你只是沒有賺到錢
不然你後面就要被套牢了
因為他變復乖離
如果他復乖離又是空頭
這跟KK是空頭
那你做空單
只要沒有上20均你就繼續報
你就去報 股價負乖離空單就繼續報
那這個也是可以 大家做一個長線的思考
我這個空單做空了嘛
那我就看 只要你沒有變正乖離
我就不要急著回補
那你就會 有的時候
就會報到很長的一段
就會報到很長一段
好 至於大家知道 乖離率
它就像是一個警示燈開始閃囉
並不是說閃了
股價就一定會漲貨是跌
但是你心裡面
就要把這個風險開始埋進來了
然後再搭配您所參考的均線
那通常乖離率是
我們是以越均線作為參考
但是你現在心裡面一定有疑問囉
那我要到哪裡去找這個乖離率呢
而且剛剛趙華也有說了
不是只有15% 20%
有的股票乖離率
四五十% 六十%
我們都看過
這個排行榜一排下來
你就會很清楚
誰是現在的標股
標股該怎麼做對不對
那這個乖離率的震盪區間
有沒有什麼規律可循呢
這些全部都在我們的榮耀班
大家趕快訂起來
榮耀班來教你看
乖離綠的排行跟去哪裡找